with year 4 almost finished up in year 5
season 1 due to be released sometime
around early June I want to take a step
back and look at something that was
shown to US during the division day
stream something that I believe confirms
the suspicions I had from the first
columns we received during Target 1
season 11. the central Aquarium
[Music]
at the beginning of season 11 we first
hear about the events that played out in
St Louis as per the division recruited
novel a rogue agent called Rowan had
drawn the attention of the outcasts they
approved of her methods and given that
they were now leaderless she had
something to offer them Direction
the attack in St Louis happened while a
cell of Agents were in pursuit of Rowan
who was on her way to attack one of the
shd cores
there were explosions buildings around
them started crumbling and this is when
Isaac announced warning radiation
detected
the outcasts were using dirty bombs
during the chunks Manhunt we would find
out that he was a former Navy nuclear
technician and was likely the reason
that he would receive a call from
Natalya Sokolova about the following
I want to assure you that this is merely
a hypothetical question okay
hypothetically what would happen to a
mortar operator if they were to use a
launcher that had previously housed a
dirty bomb
Too Many Factors to consider exposure
time amount of radioactive material
amount of transfer
what kind of particulate it wouldn't be
instantly fatal of course not
we're exposed to radiation every day by
the time you're showing symptoms of
radiation poisoning it's generally too
late thank you chunks why are you asking
no reason
I just like to be prepared for all
scenarios
if you're worried about exposure at the
plant you should start taking iodine to
protect your thyroid that's a very
useful information
what's interesting about this Intel is
what chunks did at the end there about
taking iodine to help protect the
thyroid
the reason this is interesting is
because of something that Wally said
after completing the chunks Manhunt
guess we should start looking for
natural sources of iodine just in case
should probably start eating more fish
and seaweed from mari's exhibits at the
aquarium
some of you may remember the classified
assignments that came out in year one
based on this reference after all this
time I'm actually going to be talking
about these a little bit more in
upcoming videos but this particular one
is called Central Aquarium
the mission details state that we are to
rescue a group of civilians from the
hyenas in the central Aquarium
I'm going to play through the comms that
were collected through this Mission now
to give an idea of what the aquarium
crew were going through during this time
but feel free to skip two minutes ahead
if you're familiar with them
20 000 animals in my care
ER okay we're running out of food
without that delivery we'll have to
start feeding the smaller fish to our
sharks and mammals I don't know what to
tell you sounds like you got it under
control
hello
we don't have a lot of options we're
supposed to take care of the animals not
eat them if we don't do something soon
the larger fish and mammals will starve
to death we couldn't release them you
want to throw dolly in a wagon and ask
the jtf if we could please take her back
to the Sea we've got trucks they won't
let you through the barricade I've
already talked to Sarah no one is
allowed in or out
so up I know you didn't sign on
for this but the animals are healthy
they've been well cared for the city is
full of hungry people and food is
running out so your solution is to eat
the animals we are supposed to care for
my solution is to honor them
glad they were willing to eat dolphin
when you're hungry you don't care about
politics
because you'll abandon this place not at
the animals of God we've only harvested
the Sharks and large mammals I still got
a job to do seems like a lot of work to
keep some Goldfish alive the aquarium
has a sustainable fishing program we can
reuse the tanks to turn this place into
a commercial fish farm well not
commercial but a communal fishery that's
not a bad idea we've got no idea how
long this is going to last we need
to plan for the future if you get it
going let me know
you sure are safe to eat them that tank
looks unsanitary it's algae don't you
need to add chlorine and kill it it's
not a swimming pool it's a Dolphin
Habitat we introduced the algae to prep
the Pod to be released into the wild
they were supposed to go to a sanctuary
in Florida
this is such is he okay not
really he moved here from Atlanta to
relocate the Dolphins
he's still mad at me for making this
call I get that
we all had to make some tough calls
summing up the Intel from this
assignment showed the interaction
between Mari Singh and her colleagues
they were short on supplies and worried
about what they were going to do going
forward when it came to feeding the
animals under their care
everything was locked down they weren't
able to get trucks in and couldn't
simply take the animals away
they contemplated feeding the smaller
fish to the larger fish and mammals but
this would only be a temporary solution
Murray eventually acknowledged that the
city is full of hungry people and food
is running out
perhaps the best solution was to honor
the animals and provide them as food for
the hungry population rather than just
letting the animals stuff to death
but it wasn't just about killing off the
larger animals and feeding them to
people the aquarium has a sustainable
fishing program they have the facilities
to provide a sustainable communal
fishery a source of food for the
starving civilians
now let's fast forward to the division
day stream
season one Broken Wings takes flight in
early June or doesn't fly because the
winds are broken
straight away we can see Natalia
Sokolova standing prominently above
everyone else holding a hand in such a
way that almost implies that she is the
Puppeteer and they are a puppets
I particularly like the smaller detail
of the circle of concern pin that she
has attached to his suit
the reason I see this image is
confirmation of what I suspected earlier
is because of the silhouette of a
dolphin in the background and also just
below Natalia's hand there are a bunch
of stingrays swimming past written peace
Steve Irwin also below this the
background looks very likely to be
situated in what I would assume this
aquarium facility looks like behind the
scenes
as a nerdy side note my wife and I used
to work as Equus back in the day so I'm
already geeking out on what I might see
in the season and quietly hoping that
the detail in the space has been
researched adequately because Lauren you
know I love you but I'll totally call it
out don't you be pulling any Nemo all
drains lead to the ocean
given her prominence in the comms I'm
going to assume that the person directly
under Natalya is Mari Singh and below
are her colleagues
the way Natalia is standing above them
in that domineering way isn't just
because she has commanded the Black Tusk
to take over the aquarium
if that was the case we'd probably just
take it back I think she has something
on them something they want or need
perhaps it's Murray assuming this is
Mari in the image maybe it has something
to do with the pregnancy
up until recently it seems like my wife
has been pregnant for the last five
years with my three young children so I
very much recognize their pose
so it could have something to do with
this or maybe she's been kidnapped and
taken away from the aquarium and her
friends and colleagues see no choice but
to continue to work through and do what
she says
and the agent's job will be about
finding her and making sure she remains
unharmed and returned to safety
to be fair any pregnancy during a
pandemic could be complicated there is
the issue of hygiene and the obvious
issue with inadequate medical supplies
and of course Specialists if anything
was to go wrong maybe Murray approached
someone who had resources to help and
this person was Natalia and she has
taken advantage of this situation in
turn holding the aquarium crew Ransom
however with all of this going on it
could be known of significance
but I wonder who the father is
with a few telltale signs of what we'll
be seeing in year five I have a couple
more videos to come out regarding my
speculations as well as a couple of
updates and Recaps
season three excites me so I think in
preparation I need to bring out an
updated video on Aaron keener's story as
well as a video that lines up my
weirdest speculations around what he did
why he did it and what we'll be seeing
going forward
otherwise I thank you once again for
hearing me with the weird I throw
together in video form from time to time
you're the reason I keep doing this
a big shout out to the Indian Channel
and patreon members you literally be
feeding my family
thank you very much for watching and
I'll catch you in the next one
extremists extremely remedial
[Music]
[Applause]